Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright, in Japanese we often use the term...
...as a reference to when something changes in your life that's important.
In English, we more often use the word "a milestone".
This was a milestone in my life.
So, turning point is okay but we often use the word "milestone", so please use both.
Okay, today's topic...
For example, go for it.
Go for it.
I wanna be a doctor.
Oh! Go for it!
And another one,...
...keep it up.
Keep it up.
I'm on a diet.
Oh, good! Keep it up!
So, use this for someone that's trying hard.
And last but not least,...
...hang in there.
Hang in there.
Yeah, my team just can't win.
Oh! But, hang in there!
Alright, there are many different types of...
Alright, let's repeat.
First one is go for it.
Please repeat.
Good.
The second one is oh, keep it up.
Keep it up.
Good.
And the third one is hang in there.
Hang in there.
Good.
There are a lot of different types of phrases, so...
...use the best one, and you'll sound more and more like a native.
Okay, that's it for today.
And next week, there'll be more for you in the Native Maestro...
...helping you to become the native maestro.
Thank you.